Let's sum this up. The surface color is then computed with the emissive
component, plus the ambient component, those are both solid colors. And then for
each light, there's a diffuse component which depends on the light's direction
and the specular component which depends on the light's direction and the view
direction. If you haven't seen it before, this Greek letter sigma is the
summation sign. It means to sum up all the diffuse and specular contributions
for each light. Putting math in any lecture is often considered the kiss of
death. The good news is that you can mostly ignore this equation here. It's just
another way of showing all this previous text. I put this math notation here
mostly because you'll run across this summation term a lot when looking at
material reflection models. The emissive and ambient terms are pretty simple. So
our focus for the rest of this unit will be in looking at the diffuse and the
specular terms in depth.